in a way it seemed sort of like he lived
forever but Cuban leader Fidel Castro
has passed away at the age of 90 as
announced on state television by his
brother Raul Castro saying quote the
commander-in-chief of the Cuban
Revolution died at 20 to 29 hours this
evening towards victory always which is
a reference to a revolutionary slogan of
course supporters of Castro saw him as a
leader for the people who gave Cuba to
the people while his critics said he was
a strong man communist dictator and of
course the truth is often uh quite a bit
more complex than that Castro was the
longest-serving non-royal leader of the
20th century and you might remember that
Fidel had temporarily handed over power
to his brother Raul in 2006 while he was
recovering from an acute intestinal
illness uh and then Raul Castro
officially became president two years
later more interesting to me uh about
the death of Fidel Castro so there's
this one angle which is was he a force
for good or evil and you see often uh
you know sort of predictable reactions
on that in many ways similar to what we
saw after the passing of Venezuelan
leader Hugo Chavez and and I took a lot
of heat there from a lot of progressives
actually for what was a critique of
Chavez as a strong man pseudo populists
uh leader that's that's always a
critique that exists within the left
when we see the passing or big news
related to a leader like Hugo Chavez or
Fidel Castro but more interesting to me
is that we've made so much progress on
the Cuban embargo while Fidel Castro was
still alive I mean much of that was
related to his failing health and Raul
Castro and power instead much of it was
related to Venezuela not doing well at
all as one of the chief suppliers of
Cuba
and as as out of necessity Cuba being
more open to increasing business with
the United States and I'll talk about
that a bit later but a lot of it has to
do with President Obama and this isn't
about turning the death of Fidel Castro
into a pat on the back for Obama you can
disagree with the moves that President
Obama has made up but still recognize
that President Obama was hugely uh
involved in some of these changes that
we've seen and the identity of Cuba uh
is something that has been in extra
kabli tied up in the identity of the
dell castro for a very long time his
passing even though we've seen Cuba
start to move on economically in many
ways may allow Cuba to move on
ideologically culturally in a way that
was only allowed legally by the changes
to the US relationship with Cuba that
we've seen under President Obama
although maybe not ideologically and
culturally as much and there's something
sort of I don't know if the word is
bittersweet or ironic or melancholy
about the reality that Fidel Castro will
never see the Cuba that I believe will
soon exist which will be so different
from the Cuba that existed during his
life what's the future of Cuba I mean
Raul Castro himself is 85 years old at
this time and it was suggested that the
passing of Fidel uh might totally open
the door to real systemic change in Cuba
uh we saw much of that change before his
death but we may not see more until Raul
Castro is is no longer in power uh more
broadly Castro was one of the last sort
of major players of the Cold War
Kissinger is still around and talking to
Donald Trump and we'll we'll deal with
that probably in the next week or two
some of the Khmer Rouge are still around
but but largely inconsequential at this
point the death of Fidel Castro is not
only a story about Cuba and about Castro
and about revolution but it's also a
story about President Obama and as I
mentioned before and I want to touch on
this a little more it's also a story
about Venezuela which for a long time
was supplying so much stuff to Cuba but
Venezuela is in really rough shape right
now whacking toilet paper lacking salt
all sorts of just basics lacking in
Venezuela and again in the last 60 years
we see Cuba sort of screwed again by the
downfall of another country remember
Cuba for a long time had the Soviet
Union buying sugar at hugely inflated
prices from Cuba which the Soviet Union
stopped doing in about nineteen
eighty-eight purchasing at four to five
billion dollars of Cuban sugar but an
additional addition to that one of the
primary suppliers of Cuba in terms of
oil in terms of food machinery spare
parts chemicals and lots of other
materials up so the history repeating
itself with regard to Cuba and in this
particular case really having led to
before the death of Fidel Castro changes
that many imagined we would only see
after fidel castro's death so there's a
lot of interesting pieces about the
death of Fidel we're linking to some of
them on the in the description to the
YouTube video for this segment and I
know I've already been getting a lot of
comments from people about this and I
look forward to receiving more